حسنًا ، سبب مجيئ
الشرطة وتقييد
يدي وأعطوني ثلاثة تحذيرات قبل
تقييد يدي ، قالوا لي إنني لا
تحاول الهرب ، لا تحاول
القتال معنا أو لا تحاول فعل
أي شيء غبي
[موسيقى
] لم يمنحني ذلك أي فرصة للاستيلاء على
ملابسي الشاحن أو الكمبيوتر المحمول أو
أي شيء مهم أحتاج
إلى تبديله كما تعلم حتى لا يسمحوا
لي بأي
انتهاك لطبيعة [الموسيقى]
ولكن الخطورة
يكون الانتهاك أعلى عندما يتعلق الأمر بهؤلاء الأشخاص
الذين لم يسبق لهم زيارة صربيا ، ليس لدي أي
فكرة عن مكان وجود صربيا
واللغة التي يتحدثون بها ، ما نوع
الثقافة التي
لديهم شعرت بشعور فظيع ورهيب
لأنني كنت طالبًا عاديًا كنت
أدرس أنا  كنت أذهب إلى الفصول الدراسية لدي
أصدقائي ولدي حياتي هناك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]